il
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débat d'entre deux tours des élections
législatives sur radio sensations et tv
fil 78 aujourd'hui coup de projecteur
sur la première circonscription des
yvelines et j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
les deux candidats qui se sont qualifiés
pour ce deuxième tour et vont donc
s'affronter dimanche prochain à tout
d'abord didier baichère de la république
en marche bonjour bonjour vous avez
obtenu 40 2% des voix dimanche dernier
puis françois-xavier bellamy en
présentant des républicains et de lui
des e-bonds jours bonjour vous avez de
votre côté obtenu 27 %
merci à vous d'avoir accepté un ce débat
qui durera 26 minutes avec évidemment
attendre parole équivalent pour chacun
de vous alors au premier tour il y avait
quatorze candidats dans cette
circonscription qui couvre les villes de
montigny-le-bretonneux nuit en cours et
puis une partie de versailles le député
sortant et maire de versailles françois
de mazières ne s'étant pas représentés
suite au cumul des mandats alors dites
nous tout d'abord pour commencer cette
émission chacun votre tour est assez
rapidement s'il vous plaît votre analyse
de ce premier tour et peut-être un mot
surtout sur l'abstention qui a été assez
forte monsieur v shirt je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de clarté en fait dans le
résultat de ces élections les françaises
et les français ont décidé de donner une
majorité claire nette aux programmes des
manuels macro et au gouvernement de
d'emmanuel macron moi c'est le principal
enseignement que je vais tirer de ce
premier tour c'est vrai que l'abstention
est importante alors moins importante
probablement dans notre circonscription
puisqu'on a plus voté un que la moyenne
nationale et celle des yvelines
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même une
mobilisation qui s'est opéré maintenant
il faut rassembler pour le deuxième tour
pour rassembler tous ces
abstentionnistes et qu'il s'exprime au
deuxième tour monsieur mais il a mis le
premier tour je crois que l'enjeu c'est
une invention là il faut mobiliser tous
ceux qui se sont abstenus parce que ces
élections législatives ont un enjeu
décisif
est ce qu'on constate au cours de ces
élections notamment dans la
circonscription c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
dynamique du côté d' en marche il ya
moins d'électeurs pour en marche au
premier tour des législatives qu'au
premier tour des présidentielles
en revanche il ya une énorme
démobilisation d'un électorat qui lui
pour le coup était présent nos élections
présidentielles et donc c'est très
important voilà que chacun se sente
concerné et puissent voter quel que soit
son choix mais sur un projet qui soit
clair voter pour l'avenir de notre
territoire et surtout de notre pays
alors on va malheureusement pas pouvoir
aborder tous les points de votre
programme dans ce débat mais enfin tout
de même on va on va essayer de voir deux
ou trois sujets importants de cette
première
conscription premiers sujets importants
l'emploi je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec moi ou plutôt le chômage
qui est assez présent comme partout
ailleurs dans dans cette 1re
circonscription même si elle est moins
fort que la moyenne nationale
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises dans cette
circonscription alors d'après vous
quelles sont les urgences pour les
entrepreneurs et pour les gendarmes
c'est bellamy genre il ya plusieurs il
ya plusieurs pistes a évoqué
effectivement c'est la bataille décisive
je m'occupe des questions d'emploi à
versailles et notamment aussi comme
comme président bénévole de la mission
locale qui accompagne les jeunes qui
sont les plus en difficulté dans leur
rapport à l'emploi à l'insertion
professionnelle
je crois que l'un des premiers éléments
c'est qu'il faut évidemment qu'on libère
l'activité des entreprises et les
capacités de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont prêts à créer de l'activité et de
l'emploi
le problème c'est que notre maquis
administratif le poids de nos
réglementations les charges qui pèsent
sur le travail constitue un boulet
terrible pour tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
veulent entreprendre et créer de
l'activité
il faut aussi qu'on sache sur le terrain
reconstituer des liens locaux moi je
crois que il est nécessaire d'ouvrir une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
notamment des politiques de l'emploi
face à cette espèce d'hypersensibilité
ation de pôle emploi qui n'arrivent plus
à gérer ses 6 millions d'inscrits et
c'est parfaitement normal et
compréhensible mais il faut qu'on
réussisse à refaire localement le lien
entre notre bassin d'emploi et nos
entreprises et ça passe par une offre de
logements qui soit aussi plus équilibré
notamment à guyancourt où en ville
nouvelle pour permettre justement de de
rétablir un équilibre qui soit favorable
à la création d'emplois monsieur
pêcheurs votre président au maquereau on
va se lancer dans une grande réforme du
code du travail avec les musiques noires
macro tout à fait vous vous le disais en
introduction on a la chance sur la seule
conception d'avoir 1,4 emploi en fait
par habitant donc c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle il ya une vraie dynamique sur
cette circonscription
moi je dirais l'emploi l'éducation parce
qu'on a aussi une très belle université
qu'ils paieraient de de faire le lien
avec l'emploi maintenant des 3,9
millions d'entreprises en france et la
majorité de ces entreprises une très
très grande majorité de ces entreprises
sont des petites entreprises et elles
ont besoin qu'on simplifie le droit du
travail donc c'est ce qui a été lancé la
semaine dernière puisque le premier bloc
en fête qui sera négocié puisqu'on
aurait négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux sera sur la simplification du
droit du travail
je pense en particulier à la capacité de
signer des accords d'entreprise versus
des accords de branche ou le droit du
travail
plus on s'approchera du débat local dans
l'entreprise plus on pourra créer de
l'animal la dynamique et libérer des
énergies pour les entrepreneurs
je pense que c'est le sens de ce premier
groupe de négociation on l'a vu la
semaine dernière en discutant avec la
cfdt de renault qui est une très très
grosse entreprise qui n'a pas du tout
les mêmes besoins en matière de dialogue
social
aucune aucune pme de 10 ou 50 salariés
les effets de seuil sont extrêmement
compliqué à gérer aujourd'hui pour les
entrepreneurs dès que vous arrivez à ce
fameux seuil de 50 personnes
vous avez potentiellement vous retrouvez
avec un 6e des délégués du personnel un
comité d'hygiène et de sécurité
c'est beaucoup trop compliqué et ça fait
du frein à l'emploi de manière évidente
donc c'est ça que nous voulons
simplifier rapidement dès le mois de
septembre
parce qu'on est dans l'action maintenant
tout de suite un mois peut-être monsieur
bellamy sur cette loi qui serait pas
mais je pense qu'on a on a plein de
convergence a trouvé sur ces questions
d'emploi en tous les cas pour ma part
j'ai toujours été très clair sur les
orientations que j'ai défendre et je
porterai tout ce qu'il ira dans le bon
sens et pourquoi pas notamment dans le
projet que propose un emmanuel macron
simplement une chose importante moi j'ai
une vraie divergence sur la méthode je
crois que d'abord aujourd'hui à un grand
manque de clarté on est à la veille des
élections législatives et les français
ne savent pas exactement ce qui sera
contenue dans ce projet alors on nous
dit effectivement que c'est le temps de
la concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux en même temps les français les
citoyens sont tous concernés par cette
question du travail et c'est vraiment un
problème je crois qu'il ne soit pas au
courant de ce qui leur sera proposé et
de ce qui sera votée par nos
parlementaires et notre future majorité
dans quelques dans quelques semaines et
puis la la la la deuxième chose ça
concerne les ordonnances jeunes on sait
très bien que la question du du travail
et de notre rapport au travail est une
question qui est extrêmement clivante
qui suscite de grandes inquiétudes dans
la société française et là je vois qu'il
ya une vraie divergence de méthode
si on veut que le débat soit apaisée
qu'ils soient partagés si on veut un
vrai renouveau démocratique
il me semble qu'on aurait tout intérêt à
faire vivre le débat parlementaire dans
un authentique pluralisme aujourd'hui
l'idée de passer par les ordonnances me
paraît à la fois le signe d'une
brutalité est inquiétante et surtout
aussi peut être un frein à cette à ce
partage démocratique des grands enjeux
qui touchent à la question d'emploi on
est on est tous en face à un constat
d'échec c'est à dire que les présidents
précédents au moins les deux derniers
on essayait de réformer leur du travail
et c'est palais n'a pas fonctionné mais
c'est pas les oppositions parlementaires
ce qui n'a pas fonctionné ça n'est pas
le dialogue parlementaire qui les en a
empêchés jamais votre point de vue
monsieur bellamy à un moment donné quand
tu n'as pas c'est un fait quand on n'a
pas une n'a semblé suffisamment compacte
qui est capable de faire évoluer les
choses
on est dans la situation qu'on vit
depuis 20 ans mais voilà je comprends
d'autant que je comprends d'autant moins
je comprends d'autant moins le choix des
des ordonnances que maintenant emmanuel
macron aura une majorité très clair
c'est une certitude
et donc pourquoi ne pas servir à ses
anciens juste un débat technique en fait
ce qui permet d'éviter les ambulances et
tu me fasses l'assemblée et le sénat
les ordonnances émissions vont continuer
à travailler complètement comme eux
comme c'est prévu encore une fois les
partenaires sociaux sont dans l'action
vers moi la semaine dernière encore une
fois j'étais à l'initiative de la cfdt
pour travailler avec eux sur le contenu
du texte ça y est on y va on a entendu
ce qu'ils avaient à nous dire
et dans cinquante réunions plus tard
parce qu'il ya cinquante réunions qui
sont prévues avec les partenaires
sociaux
je pense qu'on aura largement fait le
tour de la question et qu'on pourra
décider ce qu'on peut faire ou pas moi
ce que j'entends des français c'est
qu'ils veulent de l'action et des
décisions par rapport à ce qui n'a pas
été fait ces dernières années et c'est
ça qu'on propose et il faut évidemment
agir efficacement le problème c'est
qu'en fait cette méthode lava crispé le
pays et je crois vraiment profondément
c'est une vraie divergence un aléa ligne
aile et je crois audible je ne me
comprends et je comprends d'autant moins
bien ce diagnostic dans la mesure où
encore une fois jamais les oppositions
parlementaires jamais le phénomène du
pluralisme à l'assemblée nationale a
empêché un président de faire voter les
lois qu'il proposait ce sera encore
moins le cas dans l'assemblée qui se
prépare puisque elle nous donnera une
écrasante majorité selon toute
vraisemblance à emmanuel macron ce que
je crois c'est que nous aurions tout
intérêt quand on promet qui plus est le
renouveau démocratique à faire vivre ce
débat parce que la question du travail
qu une question majeure pour notre
avenir
oui on veut être prêt le 1er janvier
c'est important un les baisses de
charges qui sont prévues pour les
entreprises et pour les salariés démarre
par une adaptation d'abord du coup du
code du travail
et c'est ce calendrier la très clair
vous dites secondes séparent et ses
annonces et c'est extrêmement clair les
blocs ont été quadrillés mais le contenu
le contenu du mais pareil les
locke sont connus de manière très
précise une conférence de presse du
premier ministre et d'amis du travail la
semaine dernière les fins des blocs sont
expliqués de manière très claire on va
avancer sur sur ce débat vous parliez
des l'éducation on va on va aborder ce
sujet là alors plus de professeurs moins
d'enfants dans les classes pour ou
contre les rythmes scolaires l'autonomie
des universités alors quels sont vos
positions sur ce sujet monsieur b cher
voilà il ya beaucoup de chômage beaucoup
regardent là c'est pareil on essaie de
regarder qu'est ce qui se passe à la
rentrée et notre notre ministre de
l'éducation essaye de trier un peu dans
tous les sujets qui sont sur la table il
ya moi j'en veux dire deux sujets pour
la rentrée leleu les rythmes scolaires
et la réforme du collège sur les rythmes
scolaires ce que le ministre a dit c'est
qu'il ouvrait la possibilité aux
communes qu'il souhaitait de réouvrir le
débat dans leur commune il a pas dit de
manière uniforme comme on a toujours
fait par le passé on change tout on ne
pose pas de questions c'est ça qui a été
dit après il n'y a aucune urgence dans
cette cette mesure certaines communes
ont déjà avancé c'est le cas à
versailles c'est le cas à montigny
guyancourt probablement attendre à
l'année prochaine
je pense que le temps de la concertation
est important parce que comme toujours
dans ces débats on va se retrouver avec
50% des gens qui sont pour revenir à la
semaine de quatre jours et 50 % des gens
qui sont contre parce que ils vont avoir
une organisation personnelle qui va être
compliqué à remettre en place deux ans
après l'avoir changé
donc c'est ce temps là qu'il faut
organiser je pense que les différentes
mairies aujourd'hui on consultait aussi
les conseils d'école comme tout
changement c'est compliqué mais en tout
cas il n'y a pas de volonté ni de
position dogmatique de notre part de
vouloir changer tous dès le 1er
septembre
il faut prendre le temps de la
concertation sur les deux mains sur le
thème des collèges c'est pareil je pense
que sur les mois on va prendre les
exemples emblématiques mais sur les
classes bilangues c'est des choses qui
pouvait fonctionner qui était attendu
c'est très en lien aussi je pense avec
cette volonté d'être très européen et de
reprendre la direction de l'europe avec
notre partenaire allemand
donc on a tout intérêt à continuer à
voir ses classes on peut apprendre
l'anglais ou l'allemand d'ailleurs
sansan sans difficulté pas de position
dogmatique encore une fois sur le sujet
il va falloir revoir les projets
pédagogiques avec les directeurs
d'établissement sur l'éducation monsieur
lamy sur la question de l'école franck
on est devant un sujet décisif pour
notre avenir décisif parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons dans un pays
où 15% des élèves terminent leur collège
sans maîtriser les éléments les plus
fondamentaux notamment en matière de
lecture d'écriture de leur propre langue
nationale est donc cette injustice
sociale redoublé et dramatique et
évidemment il faut s'engager massivement
pour permettre de la deûle à résorber
bien sûr sur les deux points vous avez
évoqué je pense qu'on parle de réformes
qui ont été catastrophiques
catastrophique et de ce point de vue là
évidemment il faut que chacun aussi
assume ses responsabilités moi je vais
me rappelle du moment où monsieur b cher
au conseil municipal dans le groupe
socialistes et divers gauche défend des
la réforme des rythmes scolaires et nous
expliquer que nous étions en tort de ne
pas l'appliquer assez vite
je crois vraiment moi pour ma part que
cette réforme a été un pas de plus dans
la fragilisation de la transmission des
savoirs et de la connaissance qui
s'opérait à l'école qu'elle avait aussi
un moment de plus dans la dans la
brutalité des réformes qui se sont
imposées d'en haut est effectivement je
crois que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale actuelle a très bien fait de
redonner une liberté aux communes moi ce
que je crois c'est que demain si on
prend le temps de la concertation on
verra que c'est pas 50 50 mais une très
grosse majorité de parents sont
favorables à la suppression de cette
réforme qui épuisent leurs enfants qui
les empêchent d'apprendre correctement
il faut qu'on avance vers quelque chose
qui soit plus équilibrée et j aspire
profondément sur la question de
l'abrogation de la réforme des collèges
évidemment elle est absolument
nécessaire elle aussi parce que elle a
encore diminué le temps consacré aux
enseignements les plus fondamentaux en
allant à contre sens de tout ce que nous
savons nécessaire pour les élèves
et là pour le coup je crois qu'il faut
être extrêmement vigilant monsieur
blanquer donne de très bons signes sur
ce sujet je crois qu'il est pragmatique
mais est ce qu'il aura les moyens
d'aller jusqu'au bout de son de ses
choix sur la question des classes
bilingues sur la question des langues
anciennes qui sur lesquels des photos
ont déjà été annoncé il ya déjà des
inquiétudes notamment de la part des de
la part des syndicats d'enseignants
parce que les moyens ne vont pas avec
les annonces qui ont été faites
donc il va falloir beaucoup de vigilance
pour qu'on passe des bonnes intentions
aux véritables actions il ya sur cette
circonscription je le disais une
université qui compte dans le paysage
français
actuel comment allez vous voilà gérer
gérer c'est tous ces étudiants qui
seront les futurs employés l'employé de
demain on va gérer tous les études je
pense qu'il faut il faut qu'on remette
de la concertation entre les entreprises
et et l'université elle existe déjà
moi je travaille à guyancourt et j'ai la
chance d'être une entreprise qui recrute
plus de 2000 personnes par an donc je
vois la difficulté nous avons à recruter
aujourd'hui il ya par exemple
alors oui c'est un exemple mais je pense
que sur les docteurs par exemple il ya
un travail de fond qu'il faudra que nous
fassions
c'est une population qui souvent a du
mal à avoir accès à l'entreprise
et c'est aussi une population qui est
souvent mal connue des entreprises ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans les autres
pays
donc en particularité française là qui
fait qu'on pense toujours recherche
fondamentale quand on pense aux docteurs
ont en fait la majorité se retrouve sur
le marché du travail et je pense qu en
ayant un dialogue
les enseignants venant dans les
entreprises et les enseignants et les
entreprises allant à l'université on
peut faire mieux connaître cette filière
et avoir un débouché de recrutement
extrêmement intéressant que nous avons
du mal à capter et de la simplification
aussi à faire un jeu j'étais un débat
hier où on a parlé de la difficulté de
monter les contrat cifre donc ils sont
cédés trois ans quand on est dans le
domaine de la recherche
honnêtement si on est une pme du secteur
de l'innovation c'est des dossiers
administratifs qui sont très très lourd
à monter
même chose pour l'apprentissage c'est le
sait le deuxième bloc de négociation
pour le mois d'avril l'année prochaine
si on veut arriver à l'ambition que le
premier ministre a donné que la france
soit le premier pays de formation à
travers l'apprentissage doit falloir
énormément simplifié l'administratif
là encore les grosses entreprises
arrivent à gérer toute cette armada
administrative pour des entreprises plus
petites
embaucher un apprenti c'est compliqué
administrativement notre enjeu sur cette
première circonscription ce sont les
transports et la mobilité sont très
présents très utilisé par les habitants
le bus lagarde
damman évidemment celle de saint quentin
et même même les routes alors que
reste-t-il à faire ou que faut-il faire
pour plus de confort et de sûreté lancer
dans ces transports
youtube est là mais je voudrais juste
revenir un instant sur l'action de
l'université puisque gérard yvé
l'occasion m'exprimer je crois
qu'effectivement c'est là aussi un sujet
important pour notre territoire en
particulier il ya un sujet national qui
est effectivement de reconstruire des
filières universitaires qui soit
efficace et la question n'est pas
seulement celle de la connexion avec les
entreprises
il ya aussi beaucoup de formations
universitaires qui déboule
sur notamment sur les métiers la
fonction publique de l'enseignement par
exemple aujourd'hui malheureusement
l'université elle est fragilisée
profondément par la crise de notre
enseignement primaire et secondaire
puisque c'est la seule filière non
sélective et on le voit encore ces jours
ci avec le développement des notamment
dans les filières de formation en
médecine du tirage au sort qui est
vraiment un drame pour notre formation
républicaine parce que quand on en vient
à ce type de sélection aléatoire c'est
qu'on a c'est qu'on a vraiment perdu
quelque chose de très profond dans le
coeur de notre système de formation
donc il faut redonner à l'université les
moyens d'assumer une mission qui soit
celle d'une véritable excellence et puis
localement il ya un vrai sujet pour
notre université de versailles saint
quentin à laquelle on tient tellement je
travaille avec elle depuis 2008 va la
com com com maire-adjoint à versailles
et et je vois bien à quel point le
l'enjeu est fondamental de réussir à
faire en sorte qu'elles soient connectés
aux pôles de saclay est aujourd'hui le
grand lycée qu'elle se trouve
marginalisé dans le développement de ce
grand pôle qui se construit sur le
territoire de saclay et ça rejoint la
question des transports que vous posiez
à l'instant puisque pour faire le lien
entre l'université et saclay mais aussi
pour faire le lien évidemment entre
notre territoire et ce pôles de saclay
mais aussi l'aéroport d'orly il faut
vraiment qu'on milite de façon active
pour l'arrivée de la ligne 18 dans nos
villes avant 2024 je crois que c'est
vraiment un enjeu majeur et c'est sur ce
sujet que je veux que je me battrai avec
l'agglo maire de montigny avec la
présidente de la région ile de france
avec le maire de versailles bien sûr
parce que je crois que là nous avons un
sujet décisif pour le développement y
compris le développement économique de
notre territoire des transports est
essentiel l essentiel alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya des débats
moi j'ai habité longtemps voisins
bretons donc je peux comprendre après le
débat enterrez pas enterré sur sur cette
partie de de la ville de saint quentin
en yvelines fin de la communauté de
saint quentin en yvelines
mais à un moment donné il faut aussi
qu'on soit très clair sur les
faisabilités parce que c'est pas la
peine de laisser penser que peut-être on
augmentera le budget de cette ligne de
20 milliards si en fait en termes de
géologie on n'arrive pas à creuser
réellement ou qu'on va fragiliser les
sols et on connaît que les sols de saint
quentin en yvelines qui mettait beaucoup
bâti sur des marais donc c'est il ya
beaucoup de maisons qui ont des
problèmes à 50 ans à cause de ça dont je
pense qu'il faut qu'on veut mettre de la
clarté très rapidement là dessus
ni un danger aussi pour les jeux
olympiques sur sur ces transports on ne
voyait que le vélodrome c'est au
vélodrome hier et on sait très bien
malgré la proximité de la gare la
capacité à absorber l'afflux qui va
arriver n'est pas résolu aujourd'hui
donc c'est aussi une opportunité je
pense pour le territoire de profiter en
plus de ces jeux olympiques en 2024 pour
capter des financements et s'assurer
qu'on a des modes de transports
alternatifs aussi qu'ils sont qui sont
mis en place
maintenant on a la chance honnêtement
que ce soit versailles saint quentin on
a des gars en centre ville ce qui fait
qu'en termes d'insécurité ça n'est pas
parfait mais ça permet quand même ces
gars de centre-ville quand même de
contenir l'insécurité justement
puisqu'on parle de la sécurité et la
sûreté et il ya quand même une sécurité
qui compte dans ce secteur qu'est ce
qu'il faut à votre avis mettre en place
pour justement apaiser ces tensions
peut-être rassuré quand même les les
habitants on parle beaucoup de ça au
niveau national donc ça peu apeurés les
gens de la circonscription
monsieur bel ami il ya plusieurs pistes
qui sont importantes quand on parle de
l'insécurité aujourd'hui on parle de
réalités très différentes depuis le la
menace terroriste vit à l'insécurité du
quotidien donc c'est très difficile
d'avoir un propos qui soit trop
générales sur ces sujets je dirais
qu'une des pistes majeures moi que je
vois sur le terrain c'est que il faut
vraiment redonner leur place à nos
forces de police et de gendarmerie qui
sont aujourd'hui happé par le poids des
tâches administratives qui pèsent sur
elle
on estime que le fait de simplifier les
tâches administratives et notamment en
utilisant tous les outils le numérique
peut nous donner le dépôt de plainte en
ligne etc
ça permettrait de remettre 5000
policiers et gendarmes sur le terrain et
rien que ça je croise à nouveau
donnerait des capacités d'action
aujourd'hui notre état est très
fragilisée dans ses missions régaliennes
et il faut vraiment je crois qu'on
arrive à prendre conscience de cette
fragilité parce que effectivement l
insécurité est une véritable injustice
pour ceux qui la vivent et je sais
qu'elle est ressenti notamment très
fortement mais dans certains quartiers
nos circonscriptions dans chacune de nos
trois villes d'ailleurs où on a le
sentiment d'une forme de délitement il
faut vraiment qu'on arrive à remettre de
la sécurité c'est la condition du lien
social
monsieur chère c'est un des points c'est
un des points majeurs du programme avec
la création de la police de sécurité
quotidienne il faut aussi permettre et
je partage le point c'est aussi libérer
du temps administratif pour pour les
policiers pour les permis leur permettre
d'être dans cette mission de dialogue
sur le terrain c'est le dialogue avec
les commerçants et avec les parents moi
je les ai vus dans les échanges à
guyancourt
il y avait une espèce de voile à de peur
pas forcément justifiées toujours mais
avec une demande d'aidé c'est vrai que
la police n'est pas suffisamment
présente et il ya une envie du retour du
dialogue avec les parents et que
reprendre ce rôle de police de proximité
ou tout simplement pour essayer de
reconstruire du dialogue dans ces
quartiers c'est pas c'est pas simple ça
rejoint le débat national vous le disiez
je regardais les chiffres rapidement on
a aujourd'hui deux mille personnes qui
sont dans des radicalisation religieuse
extrêmes qui sont identifiés il ya douze
mille personnes qui sont fichés s on a
cette capacité identifié les personnes
maintenant comment on gère le
l'antiterrorisme donc le président de la
république a mis en place cette cellule
du conseil national de défense contre le
terrorisme qui lui est rattachée
directement
c'est une première étape mais on va pas
rester non plus dans l'état d'urgence on
est dans l'état d'urgence depuis le 14
novembre 2015 si je dis pas de bêtises
donc c'est long on sait qu'il sera
prolongée jusqu'au mois de novembre
parce que le temps que l'assemblée soit
constituée on peut pas avancer mais
voilà il ya des vrais sujets qui
touchent aussi aux libertés dont je
pense qu'il faut être très vigilant sur
sur ces points maintenant on peut pas
crier au loup non plus tout le temps on
connaît la situation on voit toutes les
semaines malheureusement on l'a vu
encore à londres dernièrement il ya des
attentats donc il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement vigilant et qu'on prenne nos
responsabilités sur sur ces sujets juste
un mot peut-être je crois que là ça nous
fait une il ya une divergence majeure
entre nous qui vient d'être exprimée par
monsieur b cher monsieur chère parle du
retour de la police de proximité je
crois que dans cette période qui est
marquée effectivement par des
inquiétudes fortes au tour de la
radicalisation autour du terrorisme il
faut qu'on redonne à la police son vrai
métier
nos collectivités elles sont là sur le
terrain pour faire de l'animation de
territoire elles sont les les forces de
l'ordre ne sont pas là pour servir de
police de proximité ça a été je crois un
échec majeur des dernières années il
faut qu'on arrive effectivement à
remettre la police sur le terrain mais
pour faire son vrai métier et non pas
pour faire de l'animation sociale sur la
radicalisation en particulier
on peut pas prendre des grandes
décisions centrales
moi je crois et c'est une vraie
divergence entre nous et je l'assumé
vraiment je crois qu'au contraire si on
avait gardé cette police de proximité
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui l'avait
supprimée on aurait peut-être identifié
beaucoup plus tôt ces éléments de
radicalisation et on le voit dans les
quartiers en a on a la chance de
circonscription d'être vraiment une
circonscription plutôt calme avait pas d
énormes difficultés
par contre certains quartiers
effectivement ont besoin d'être regardée
et d'avoir une vie avec la police de
proximité beaucoup plus importante qui
n'ont aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
identifierait très en amont sur les très
jeunes les tentations de radicalisation
ça permet de d'améliorer le vivre
ensemble c'est important aussi
non mais voilà c'est ça qui est très
important c'est effectivement la
prévention de la radicalisation elle est
décisive nous aussi on a des antennes
sur le terrain et il faut je suis
d'accord avec vous décentraliser cette
action le problème c'est qu emmanuel
macron avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation par exemple montre la
volonté d'une nouvelle centralisation
totalement à rebours de l'histoire est
là aussi il faudra qu'on soit vigilant
mais je crois que la police elle est là
précisément pour faire son métier
je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
investir massivement sur le
renseignement humain qui a été largement
déployé ses moyens au service de moyens
technologiques qui ne sont pas toujours
capables en fait de détecter les vrais
problèmes
en revanche la police est là pour faire
son travail et pas pour organiser comme
ça a été le cas pendant la période
socialiste des matchs de foot dans les
quartiers ça nous permet de prévenir
personne n'a dit qu'on allait tomber
dans la caricature proximité et je sais
pas ce que c'est faux mais chers
policiers ce qu'on préfère aujourd'hui
on n'a pas dit qu'on allait organiser
des matchs de foot dans les quartiers je
veux mettre la police sur le terrain
mais pour répondre à votre question
demandé à la police de gier et le lien
social demandé à l'armée d'organiser un
service militaire d'un mois pour régler
les problèmes d'éducation des jeunes
tout ça c'est autant de façons de
gaspiller nos forces de sécurité et de
défense aux alors qu'ils auraient besoin
de se concentrer sur leur métier
justement puisque puisqu'on parle du
vivre ensemble des quartiers parlons en
quelques minutes ce qu'il n'en reste que
très peu de la pauvreté et du pouvoir
d'achat et comment améliorer cela le
président macron propose des choses au
niveau notamment des impôts baisse des
impôts vous l'avez dit par rapport aux
charges
qu'est ce que vous pourriez faire vous
pour hacker ce courrier dire aux gens de
cette 1ère circonscription on sera
vigilant sur le collectif budgétaire du
venger
novembre verra en fonction de calendrier
de de l'assemblée il ya énormément de
réformes à mettre en place sur ces
sujets là il ya l'augmentation de 100
euros du minimum vieillesse
il ya l'élargissement du socle de la csg
qui fait beaucoup parler d'ailleurs sur
notre circonscription suivant si on
avait menti n'est plus en cour à
versailles on n'a pas la même réaction
parce que oui 20 % des retraités
globalement pour être impactés par ce
set cet impact de l'augmentation de 80%
non 20% des votes particulièrement
impacté articulièrement voix
particulièrement parce que la côte
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
concerne les habitations elle sera
forcément compensé par l'état donc c'est
toujours les français qui vont la payer
c'est une espèce de mélange d'économie
matthew bellamy suffit de regarder le
plan économique perdure crise mais vous
n'allez pas faire disparaître les
communes a dit que les financements qui
leur sont allouées vont continuer elles
seront comblés à 100% on a été
extrêmement clairs là dessus ils seront
toujours donc les vend ses parts à
descendre sous les yeux par les français
sur le pouvoir d'achat oui c'est
extrêmement important
la baisse des cotisations avec la
suppression des cotisations maladie et
chômage pour les salariés c'est une
aubaine incroyable pour recommencer à
consommer donc ces mesures là vont se
mettre en place d'ici au 1er janvier
elles ont un impact direct sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français vous bien
sûr effectivement je crois que là la
question de la hausse de la csg est une
question majeure et si je suis élu je je
serais moi pour le coup vigilant avec
les moyens que donne l'indépendance
d'une d'une opposition pour pouvoir
essayer de rééquilibrer cette décision
que je crois catastrophique parce que la
hausse de la csg elle va pénaliser
on le disait à l'instant une majorité de
retraités elle va pénaliser aussi
n'ayant pas peur de le dire les
indépendants et aussi les fonctionnaires
parce que les fonctionnaires eux pour le
coup ne profiteront pas de cette baisse
de cotisations salariales que vous
évoquez à l'instant or aujourd'hui la
pauvreté
c'est la grande pauvreté mais c'est
aussi la précarisation de beaucoup de
travailleurs et en font partie aussi
beaucoup de fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas
vu leurs revenus augmenter depuis très
longtemps je suis enseignant je vois
comment ça se passe sur le terrain
je crois que c'est un sujet majeur pour
notre avenir c'est la femme se débat
déjà merci à vous deux d'avoir fait
didier baichère donc de la république en
marche et françois-xavier bellamy
représentant des républicains et du diy
on se retrouve évidemment dimanche pour
une soirée spéciale sur nos antennes la
radio sensations et tv fil 78
en attendant bonne fin de semaine à tous
merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]